elle est avec nous véronique hivon
députée du parti québécois dans joliette
que vous connaissez bien l'un me vont
tout le monde n'avait que de bons mots
pour vous aujourd'hui d'ailleurs vous
êtes une des rares
qui fait l'unanimité vous avez plutôt
des et l'aja plupart du temps vous êtes
quand vous êtes bénis vous avez votre
travail a fait pour le droit à mourir
dans la dignité entre autres que ja il
ya un grand respect que s'est installée
mais écoutez je ne sais pas c'est
peut-être plus à des analyses de le dire
je suis très surprise de ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui
c'est ce que je me sens extrêmement
reconnaissante d'avoir pu c'est tous ses
liens avec autant de gens qui nous ont
amenés à accous construit retrait des
réformes et puis c'est sûr que quand
j'ai fait le saut en politique je
m'étais fait une promesse c'est qu'il y
avait tellement de gens désabusés de la
politique qui trouvait que c'était tout
du pareil au même but que c'était des
fois un circle salon bleu que je voulais
vraiment rebâtir la confiance à l'égard
de la politique y compris pas juste sur
les réformes de fond mais sur la manière
qu'on exerce la politique alors c'est
sûr que de ce côté de sentir ses
commentaires le sujet là ça me fait ça
me fait chaud au coeur et là pourquoi
exactement vous sentez étouffé vous
sentez prisonnière la ligne de
particules pourquoi à ce moment ci
pourquoi tout simplement parce qu'avant
de renouveler nos voeux en quelque sorte
avec avec l'engagement politique je
pense qu'il faut vraiment aller voir ce
qui en nous et moi quand je me suis
lancé en politique je pensais faire deux
tout au plus trois mandats j'en ai fait
quatre et puis en fait j'ai vraiment le
pendant des mois son démon nord mais mon
coeur parce que j'adore ce que je fais
j'ai encore plein de combativité et puis
j'ai aimé chaque minute la vie politique
mais je dois dire qu'il ya ce besoin le
qui revenait toujours à la surface
d'avoir un plus grand espace de liberté
un espace de normalité parce qu'à un
moment donné après 14 ans vie politique
c'est comme si il ya beaucoup de figures
imposées il ya beaucoup de
l'instantanéité
il ya peut-être des flammes à la ligne
de parti c'est certain mais je pense que
au delà de ce seuil comme un espèce de
réalité que à chaque jour on se lève on
lit 4 5 jours d'où ce que c'est mais on
doit avoir des réactions surtout tout le
temps il n'y a pas beaucoup de place à
la nuance à prendre son temps puis c'est
tout des choses avec lesquelles j'ai
bien composé mais là j'ai le goût de
voir autre chose j'ai le goût de même de
contribuer autrement en ayant un petit
peu plus d espace de réflexion puis de
peau juste comme je les dis à être
existé par et pour la politique quand
vous dites contribuer autrement que vous
renoncez à jamais une carrière politique
ou à vous dites on verra bah écoutez
c'est une décision mûrement réfléchie
puis c'est sûr que je filme clairement
un chapitre est ce que je ferme le livre
au complet pour toujours aujourd'hui ce
serait trop difficile de vous dire parce
qu'il ya quand même d'un petit deuil une
désintoxication que je vais devoir faire
mais c'est certain que le jeu je me me
réalisés puis je veux accomplir des
choses avec les québécois autrement dans
votre prise de décision madame hivon ce
que vous êtes dit c'est sûr que ça va
être interprété comme étant je quitte
parce que le pq est en train de mourir
est ce que vous êtes même dit je peux
pas m'en aller ça va avoir l'air
épouvantable chez un des piliers de ce
parti là en fait je veux dire je suis
pas folle je suis la politique fait que
je savais que ce serait un élément qui
pourrait être amenée c'est sûr mais
c'est tout ce que ce matin j'ai fait en
quelque sorte une frappe préventive je
les dis que savait rien à voir avec ça
ça absolument rien à voir à moins que ce
soit 0 connecter sur moi même puisque
des gens qui lisent dans mon inconscient
je peux vous dire que ça aucun rapport
car maintenant quand même quand même je
vous pousse là dessus parce que si le
parti québécois était à 32
pouvait à une chance de prendre le
pouvoir change rien ça changerait rien
ça peut vous paraître drôle mais
honnêtement moi le pouvoir pour le
pouvoir j'y crois pas puis je pense que
je tends un exemple qui ont pu réaliser
des choses dans l'opposition le moal et
les trois corps si c'est pas plus de ma
vie politique je les ai vécus dans
l'opposition j'étais 18 mois ministre
c'est tout j'ai quand même réalisé des
réformes donc pour moi c'est vraiment
pas une fin en soi c c c c c'est ce
constat qu'on aspire qu on va en
politique évidemment de pouvoir avoir
tous les leviers décisionnel je pense
qu'il ya plein de choses qu'on peut
faire autrement qui honnêtement j'ai
jamais cru dans la politique basée sur
une seule personne je crois dans les
mouvements qui viennent de la base le
parti québécois est un parti de base
avec beaucoup de monde je pense qu'on
est capable de se retrousser les manches
ça évidemment voir une lunette roses
penaud arc en ciel devant nous je pense
qu'on est vraiment capable d'attaquer
les choses et les défis qu'on le doit on
voyait aujourd'hui un sondage le parti
québécois est à 9% de ses yeux le plus
bas depuis que vous militez évidemment
parti québécois qu'est ce qui se passe
d'abord puis est ce que vous craignez
pas que le parti ne meure non parce que
je vois pas comment un parti le seul
parti qui porte la cause de
l'indépendance
pourrait disparaître je pense que le
québec a besoin du parti québécois je
pense que nous on a besoin parti
québécois de reconnecter cette grande
cause
en fait je pense qu'il ya eu beaucoup de
désillusions
il ya eu beaucoup de désillusions puis
je pense que on avait besoin de
rattacher ce projet le à la vie concrète
des gens le jeu dur qui vivent
l'inflation qui ont pas de place en cpe
donc pour moi ce projet le il résonne
dans toutes les sphères de notre vie
collective ou individuelle aussi je
pense que il faut se pousser à faire ce
évidemment il ya du travail de
reconstruction et de volant avec respect
j'entends ce depuis créé 120 étant dit
il faut reconnecter avec les militants
auraient expliqué et manifestement il ya
quelque chose qui ne fonctionne pas
actuellement mois en fait je pense que
trop longtemps le projet d'indépendance
été vue un peu comme un idéal d incarner
du reste de la vie c'est quelque chose
au contraire qui est incarnée dans la
vie des gens et vous savez quand on voit
les sondages on parlait de sondages mais
sondage après sondage est encore 30 à 40
% des québécois qui se disent souveraine
et ce qu'ils disent indépendantiste mais
ce n'est pas leur priorité quand ils
font leurs choix je pense que nous notre
enjeu ce pourquoi faut se relever les
manches et surprendre c'est de dire que
à un moment donné il va falloir se faire
assez confiance comme québécois pour se
dire qu'on est capable de dire oui pis
la différence que ça ferait évidemment
qu'il ya beaucoup de travail que les
grandes causes nécessite du gros travail
des grosses remises en question puis je
pense qu'avec la relève qu'on a on est
capable de surprendre à la prochaine
élection en étant très réaliste très
réel et voit surprendre été enlevée
puis je dire quand on est des députés
puis un parti de cause d'idéal c'est pas
une fin en soi le pouvoir donc d'avoir
des députés d'en avoir plus c'est
toujours mieux mais ça fait des gens qui
se battent puis je pense qu'on a besoin
d'avoir ces gens là avec nous au québec
monsieur legault a eu des bons mots pour
vous a dit j'ai travaillé avec elle dans
lanaudière j'ai travaillé au parti
québécois avec elle et c'est bravo puis
bonne continuation est ce que pareil en
vous craignez pas que lors de la
prochaine campagne dans la prochaine
élection la cac dont le voyage avec les
francophones la halle est omniprésent
prennent tout l'espace politique est ce
qu un côté malsain selon vous c'est
certain je pense qu'une saine démocratie
je dire les gens ont jamais tard donc
c'est les électeurs qui décident mais je
pense que dans une saine démocratie le
combo le débat autour des idées de
positionnement différent est fondamental
c'est comme ce qu'on est capable de
faire ressortir le meilleur de nous
mêmes c'est en opposant c'est le choc
des idées donc c'est sûr que je pense
que la diversité point de vue elle est
fondamentale le plus beau a terminé en
quelques secondes et le plus laid en
politique le plus beau le plus beau
c'est de réussir à faire des changements
qui touchent la vie des gens dans le
plus concret comme évidemment les soins
de fin de vie plein médicale a montré
les tribunaux spécialisés je pense que
c'est sûr quand on a des témoignages de
gens qui disent que ça a changé la vie
le plus laid je dirais c'est si c'est
parfois ce ce manque de civilité cette
espèce de
réflexe ultra partisans de penser que la
personne en face de nous est un ennemi
alors qu'elle est tout au plus un
adversaire politique on devrait avoir du
respect pour tous ceux et celles qui
font ce choix mais on est qui vont vous
retrouver ou dans 1 en tunisie avait
vraiment pas non j'ai fait le saut dans
le vide en me lançant politique qui
puisse faire une autre saut dans le vide
je vous laisse aller véronique hivon
merci beaucoup député de joliette encore
quelques semaines merci merci au revoir
la prochaine